[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants bonsoir tous au trot
qui a team nounours pensez vous qu'il
soit trop tard pour faire du boul mais
non tu peux t'amuser avec tes amis et
faire du bruit encore un petit instant
les mamans le taureau rouge
je suis certain qu'elle te donne la
permission wahou que diriez-vous les
enfants si nous chantions tous ensemble
avec nicolas et pimprenelle une belle
chanson les propos topo vos propos
la nf nous chantons sur la route de
louviers oui c'est un la route d'el nino
vieira
louvier sur la route de louviers ya peu
en compte ni il y avait d'un cantonnier
mais quitte à celle du cochonnet
canétois
dédicace à des cailloux on a du passage
des roues
[Musique]
une date a passé une belle dame va tu as
passé dans sa peau carrosse doré dans sa
peau
quant à lui
gagné de plus et qui lui pique aux
cotonniers
fiches métiers
les campagnes
la cotonnière afcot faut que nos visions
deux garçons
rigueur car lyon car si jolie antarès
qu'au caractère car si je roule au score
c'est ta soeur dont intel
cette réponse se fait remarquer cette
réponse je fais remarquer par sa grande
simplicité
[Musique]
ce qui prouve que ceux qui pensent que
les malheurs voilà le coeur
[Musique]
d'une annonce il ya beaucoup de
malheureux oui beaucoup trop comme la
campagne et oui
et des petits enfants malheureux cana
aussi oui il faut pas c'est pas bien non
heureux mais on veut pas que malheureux
je le sais mais cher petit halo ali
on ne fait pas toujours ce qu'on veut
annie lennox ou pro de nuit les enfants
là j'éteins la lumière
faite de poudre
[Musique]
mais
alors nounours vous avez bien chanter we
pas trop qu'est ce que tu as tu es
triste pas trop je veux que tous les
enfants soit heureux oui nounours
allons en route bonne nuit des enfants
embrasser bien fort vos parents allez
vite vous couchez les feuilletons pour
[Musique]
oh
où